[Music]
everybody start action episode 8 gosh
the first film didn't even have a number
Ryan has written a story that's
unexpected but right
some of the stuff that happens people
gonna be not oh my god
even though I think I know it all they
throw things have any story wise I never
could have imagined and even though
everybody knows it's the second in a
trilogy it feels like it's own thing
Star Wars is so cool because there's all
these creatures
visual effects
but all the characters are also so
complex
Brian nice the workers Wilkie sells
particular new director Connie business
Lana working sound
it feels like the storylines become more
established
we're really getting to know these new
characters also with the characters that
we know and love
their lives change
everything's being shifted in the
opposite way to what the audio is
expected after seven
Brian's made Star Wars fresh and new
I'm hoping it'll be a little shocking
but I'm hoping it'll feel real and
honest
the fermentation story of good against
evil
told in the most fascinating way but it
has a real spiritual depth to it
it's about family and that's what's so
powerful about it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
for me
[Music]
reach out like
[Music]
darkus
the balance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I only know one truth
it's time for the Jedi to end
[Music]